дебати матч ви краще 1 значення для у
всіх кандидатів вікі завелася і нацисти
вони
Аліна більше користі diablo para que todo
нинішній лідеркою президентських
виборів марин ле пен справа радикального
національний фронт the center is the
емануелем акрон а macron назвавши звірятко
у кому свіжо палітрі та французька
політесі не по в'язаних із традиційним
партіям господиня ж моя платформа куля
гауда курячих зрадах
з новим виглядом і новим шляхом і
звалиться і повернути Україну те й енергію в
чесного ефективно систем ще вселяючи
нади і марин ле пен так позитивну
якби я поза перебуваємо на кандидатці вона
пообіцяла жорстку роти зв'язку краще нести
татор рам і у філіпа металу пансіон
убити батька ще 2006 можна заплутатися і
вітчиму венеру б всього колибу прем'єр у
нас правді ми заткнулася від бух розумні
стабільності так ви бух розумний
стабільності нас чи то сталося ті
дороги або та надзвичайно dex пляж для свічки
цієї при камбрі юляш розкритих увала
macron а то кандидата адже соціаліст
бенуа амона за їх нелояльність досвіду не
іммігрантів з мусульманських crying на
тому дуже крон званого ти в лапин ubr
їх не французькому народу метаючи кай
розколоти україну дотримуючи куртку лелик
диво імміграції де стала сама крону і
вид консервативного кандидата
франсуа фійона я повністю не дзвін з
емануелем акрон розум і зміцнювати свій час
візиту до Берліна
дав високу оцінку німецький канцлер сізо
імміграційну політику віджати
політика виявилося а погану і зацінь
адже критикує на партій не союзник
вважали дебати стала першою з трьох
запланованих парадне голосування 20
Рачок видно досвіду Ваня показав і 40
вибір тиф до синяви значилося все
своїм і спади лазнями